[APPLAUSE]
WEEKEND YEAH,LMOS THEWEEKEND.
[APPUSE]
CL AWAY M LITTLERIENDS
HAY FRIDAY EVEONE.
IT H BEE A GOO WEEK AND
BAD ONE.
GENDY WRITER PASSE AWAY.
IT SUC BUTE WAS KIND ENOHBEFOREH
BEHI FOR ALL OF U
NOTUST SOMEMPTYHISKEY
BOLES WHICH SOUN LIKEHE
NAMEF KAT'S AUTIOGRHY.
HEEFT US SOME AMAZING BOO.
DERNANNERS AND THENES THAT
ANGEME REPUBLIN PARTY
WRECFILE.
HELSO GAVE US T OFHE
GRTEST PIECES OSATI EVER
WRTEN THE NIONAL LAMPOON
1964 HIGH SCHO YEARBOOK ANDTHE .
WASNE OF THE GRTEST
EDITS OFNE OF THE GATESTEDITS E.
HE MAY NOT EVERRITTEN AMAL
HE MADE IT HAPPEN.IT.
HE MAD ME HPEN TOO.
OKAY Y CAN'T WINHEMLL.
T HE GAVE ME HOPE AND HE GAV
ME PAT
A PLACEO GO FOR SOMNE WHO
DIDN'T FITN RELY AWHERE.
I BRING THIUP TONIGHT BAUSE
AT WARE SEEING IN TODAY'S
LEGACY.S IMPARTJ PJ
WHAT HE D FOR THE RIGHT HAS
MADET OKAY FOR TH TO BE
ONG  THE BESTENSE OF T
RD.
TO BE FUNNY,O BEOOSE, TO BE
HIGH I'M AT TO B WHICH SOUS
LIKE T NAMOF MY
TOBIRAPHY.HE TOLDS IT OKAY TO BE
WHH ISVERYTHING THE
STEREOTYPEF THE RIGHT I NOT.
JUDGMENTAL.LYS HE TO BE
I DIDT HAVO LIKE CULRE T
TH LEF.
THEY HAD TIR MARY PRANKSTERS,
THEY MIGHT BON T SETHING.
D THEN CAM ANDW BREBART.
FIGHT BACK WHUN.PLPOLITICSUNS EO
WH I WAS YOUNGER WROTE A
PIECEALLED THE DEAN WARMEEFFECT.
BASEON THIS FELLA FROM TMOVIE A.
>> 0.
FAT DRUNK ANSTUP IS N WAY
TO G THROUGH LIFE'N.
YOARE O YOUE FINISHED.
I WANT YOU O TS CAMPUS A9:00 MO.
EAK T TO  TO TO MIKE TO
>>reg: THEY WERE ALWS
ANIMAL HOUSE
THCHEERFUL TROUB MAKERS.
E WISE GUY
♪
♪ ♪
THE RIGHT HAD STIC U THERE[BLEET
SCRIPT ANDEVERSE THE EFFECT.
MY INSPIRATI WASJ.
HE MADE IT CAR TT THE BY
POTICS WAS ALWAY GONNA BE
FUN.
NOW IT'S HAPNING THE BIG
WE ARE HING FUN THE AREN'T.
IT'SRIVING THEM CRAZY.
REAY DN'T HAVE TO L
LI A FGER AND WHEN WE D
THKSO PJ H ISLWAY THE
MIDDLE ONE.
ALL IT TOOKAS A LITE TRU
AND AOT OF LOC, DONALD TRUMP
SHOWUS TT WE CAN BE AS
OBNOXIOUSUNNYAND FEISTY A
TH AREND WN.
NOW PJ WAS DINITY NO FAN OFTRUM.
BUT DONALD TRU WASLL ANIMAL
HOUSEIT WAS ME LI RODNEY
DANGFIEL'S CRACTER AND
"CADDYACK.
THEY KNOW QUORAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWN AOBOTIC ROBOT HERE
LLARY CLINTON A ROBOTICOBOT
HAIRED MITT ROEY.
TOREPUBLICANS H TO HE A
GOOD TIME.
WE FOUND OURSELVES LGHINAT
E HAPLESS CNN WCH BECAME A
GIBBERING --
THEIR ENTIRE LINP BECAME ASTRINE
THEEAL WORLDAN TM OVER.
DEMOCRATIC PAR AND TO AA
POLICAL  JONESWN.
TH I HERE' TON IDEOLOGY OR
DITHE PAR OF THAT O SAID KEETHEC
ME TO BRING THE LAWYER WITH
THEM ON A DE, THE PARTYHATONCE D
SOETY NOW SMS PIGMENT BUT
NOTHINGLSE.
THPARTTHOSE PRO WOMEN NOW
REPLACES MS WH BIRTHING
PERSS.
SO TEMOCTS ARE IN AN
ALL-OUT PAN BECSE BECAUSETHEY NE
PARTIES ALL A PACHY AND
DGMENTAL PROBAY FROM THE
CONSNT PREACHING AND JUDGING.THO
TH'S WE IS H, POLITICAL
DRANO.
THEY ARE S PURANICAL THAT
EY MAKE JER BALL WELDS LOOK
LI GENE SIMMO.
THDEMOATIC PARTY ISOW AS
SUCKS THE FUNUT O EVERYTHIN
I' A FRIEND IN ALLITERURE
LOSE WEIGHT D EAT SOME O HMEALSY
ONHE REST.
IT WORKSHE STOPP EATG AND EVERYN
EVERNE ELSE'S APPITE TOO.THAT'SE
THE DEMOCRATIPARTY,UT
SO TO WEN SPORTS.
SYSTEM, IT'SN ASHTRAY LOADEWITH.
BECAUSE I CAN CATELLT
DOESSESTR.IT'S AOLITAL CONSTRUCT
FORCESUMANS TO CAN FORT IN
NATURAEMAN
THAY BFUN I BED BUTOTIN POLITS.
TOLERANCE INTIDATING A PARTY
THROUGH THATS  CANLLATN,
OBEY OR THE WILL RUINOU.
YOVE SN SIAL DIA AND ITS
MEDIACCOMPLICES.
LIKE YOUR WIFE STRINGHEIR
SUCCS WAS BASED O SRING
YOU,OT CONVINCING YOU.
SOHYAKE A GOORGUMENT WHEYOU CANS
ANDEDIACTS --
FOR EAKING THE TRUTH.
THEEMOCTIC PARTY.THEN LIKERIANRA
FRITO-Y WAREHOUSE TY EAT
EVYTHING FROM THENSID
[LGHS]
IT'S FUNNY
I WOULD SAYHAT THE DEMOCRAARE DW
IT WORSE, IT'S AGANROM THEEXORC.
E PARTY IS POSSSEDY A
DEN THAT DEFINITYEEDS AN
ORCISMECAUSE OF IT DSN'T
HAPP SOOTHEY AREOAST.
VOTERS TOERVE MORE TN THE
BAD IDS TH THEY BARF UP LIKE
LIKE TO HPUT FRANKLY I'MI WOULD
HAVI TOET OF A TIME.AN FOR THATY
ANK YOU PJ.
[APPLAE]
WELCOME TIGHT'S GUES
ANDREW CUO MORE PAIN THA HIS
HE I SO PATRIOTICE SEPSROLOGYOR.
WITHIS HAND OVE HIS HEART.
OKLAHOMA TRANSPORTATIO FRO
OKHOMA SPEAKER O THE HOUSE
T.WHANNON.
[APPLAUSE]HER BLOOTYPES MOJITO
X NEWS CONTRIBOR K TIMPF.
[APPLAUSE]
AND WN THERE IS AN EARTHQUE
SAN ANEAS SAYS IT'S S FAULT.
[LAUS]
THAT'S CUTE.
WORLD TELEVISION CHAION TYRUS
[ALAUS
JANI HOW ARE YOU
>>anic IT'S GOOD TO E
I'M A BIG FAN OU
[LAUGHS]>> Greg: H SWEET MAY WE
SHOULD JUST CA IT DAY YOU
GUYS.
THANYOU, THANK YOU
Greg: WE BN GTING A LOT
OF MAIL ABO HOW WE SHOULDE
CHANNG THE COHOST THING
[LAUGHS]
I THINK YOUE A ETTY GOOD
COHOST.
GIVE SOME TI OFF FOR KAT.
>> Kat: I NOT OFFENDED.
>> Jice: IOULD DO SOME
WEATHER.
[LAUGH
>>reg:AVE YOU NOTICED THE
SHIFT TOO.
IF YOU LOOATIM TALK ABOTHIS THET
TAKGLACE.
>> Janice: I THINK MOMARE
CHANGE THEORLDY THEAY.
IEALL FEEL THAT.DON'T MS WITH OD
BE A HASHTAG.
BECAE WT IS HAPPENIN INSCHOOLS,T
OUR KIDS, MOMS A STAING TO
RISE UP TH AREOING TO THE
MEETINGS, TH ARE SAYING THAT
WE ARE NOTOING TO TAKE IT
MOMS BEHIND STD UP AS WELL.NDSUR
IS AEVOLION OF MOMS WANTING
CHAE IN THIS COUNTRY.
USUALLY ACTIVM ANPROTESTERSDON'M
THE FE TE, SO WHEN YOUEE A
PARE THAT ISROTEING THAT'S
ACTUAL A L OF WORK.
IT UD TO BE WHEN U DIGREE
WIIBERALS, THEYOULDUST
CONSIDER YOUN EIGHTEN NOT
THAT SMART NOT THAT OF FORM.
CONSERTIVEEED IS CONSIDED
YOUODLESS.
SESS WHAT WAS.
BUNOW 'S COMPLETELY
DIERENT, NOT ONLO LIBERS
CONSID YOU NOT TO BEORTH
INLLECTUALLY, BU THE ALSO
THK THAT YOU'VE A MOR.
IF YOUON'T AGREEITH ME IN
LOSTEP 1% IN THEIR SMACH
WHIL WITH YOUR MOLITY.
TH'S THE REASONHY TYCAED ERY SIN
WHITESF PREMISES.
THEY CALL EVYONEHO DISAGREE
WITH THE EVERYTHINGUT A
AMICAN, AND UNFORNATE F
GET REWDED  T BALTOXESA
TH MIDTERMS.REPUBLICS AR GOING
HUGE WAVEYHE WAY THA THE
WOKE LEFT HA CHOSEN TOO.
Greg: WHAT ISHE WD I'M
LOOKINFOR  PENLUM.
SO WT WHAT YOU TALK ABOUT IS
THAT WE WE NO EN BORIKE
IN THE 50s.
BU WHICH ARE ABO REPRESSIVE
50s CULRE.
IT WAS THE MORALM.
A PURANICAL OBSESSEWITH
MORA BEHAVIOR.
ON.DIRECTLY GOEITH FOCUS
THAT'S THE NEWOKE IS HIM.
CONVERT TO AL THE THINGS THTHEYE
U KN SCOTT AND AMOL LIGHT.
BACKED BY STRT RELIGUS
BEEFS.
>>reg: RIGHT.
>> T.W N IT'S BKEDY
FANTY BELIEFS AREHATOUNDS
GO IN A TNK TANK.
IS WEEK.
[LGHS]
IT'SOREVER CHANGING.
WE HAVE SEEN BIG CHAE O OF
CHALLENGED JUSDIDN HAPPEN.T LIBS
PELE DO NOT CHALLEN IT
BECAE TY WERELWAYS ON THE
RIGHT SIDEF EVYTHING.
EY LIVE AT YOUR HEA AND YOUR
CHALLEE OFHAT HAPPENED WH
R FILY HAS CHAED TNGS TO
WE NOWERE SEEINGORE PEOPLE
ARE WILLING TO FIGHTGAIN THE
LIBERAL LEF BECSE HEUSTE
COERVAVES DON'T LIKET I
THE SETBA FOR CHURCH OPLE
NONE SAYING?
Tyr: WNHEEMOCTS,
LIBELS ALIKE YOU C'T GO TO
YOUR CONCERT COMYOU CAN'T DO
ANYTHING.
YOUR SIAL MEDIA YOUTYPE
EVERYONE.I THINKHEN STORY LOO BC
WH THIS THING CHANGE YR TO
BEHE FRONT OF IBECAE YOU
STARTED TO R PRBUS OR GOAT
NO ADDITIOL REON TO BE
>> Greg: Y DON'T WANT T P
WITH AN ANGRY WOKETIR
BEUSE LE AND SOCIAL DIA
AND EY WILL CREAT MOBS,LSO
>> Greg: THAT'WHAT SHUT UPL COMA
THE DOCRATS BECSE TY COULD
ALMOST CALLEDOU DA YOU SEEHOW B.
I'LL STOPT.
M KIDDING.
IT'S LIKE WH SUBD HE SNDS
UP AAKES I EASIER FOR
EVERYBY EL TO SND U.KAT, WHA YOI
U HAVE BEEN RGETEFORE.
>> Kat: IS REALLY ACTULY
CRAZYECAUSE I'M NOTREPUBLIC, N M
A MOLY LLESS HE THE
SO IT'S CRA TT I ACTUALLFEEL MON
Y THINGS IN ROOM FULOF
CONSERTIVEIN A ROOM FUL OF
LEFTISTS.
WHICH ISRAZY GIVEN THE FACT
THAT I AM AAWLE HEATH.
M TEIFIED WHEN I'M ROOMFUL
OF LEFTISTS  THEY ASK MENY
QUESONSIKE WHERE DO IORK I
[LAUGHS]TO LEAVE
>> Greg: THE WILL CHASE YOOUT TR
>>at: I'M JUST NNA GO
HOME>> Greg: THINK YOU CAN ALSO
THINK OF LAWLESS EVES LE
T, YOU SEE ONILL MARS FACE
ERYRIDAY.HE SAW THIS COMG THAT E
HAVING FUN, PELE WEREAUGHING
IN HIS AUDNCE WAST.
WAS FED UPITH IT.
TH'S WHAT YOU S HIMSE
DISTCING HIMSELF FM HIWN
RTY'HOSTILITY ANDOKE IS
M AND YOU'RE GNA KP SAYINGNOW WE
VOCAL DEMRATS.